[Music]
greg
is in raleigh north carolina hi greg
welcome to the ramsey show
hey thanks for having me appreciate you
taking the call mr dave mr ken
glad to be on sure how can we help
well so my wife and i are in this
project because we so so we've been
doing
the steps we're actually through step
four we're investing 15
um we have six months savings stored up
and we've got about an extra 10 000 now
probably by the end of next month it'll
be close to 15 because
we get an extra paycheck um and our plan
was
we have two vehicles that are older and
cheaper and they're paid for of course
no
no debt or anything else other than
house um our plan was
our family is going to be starting soon
uh we need a family vehicle
and uh so we've been saving up for that
however one of the cars we have a three
thousand dollar car we have a fifteen
hundred dollar car
the three thousand dollar car
transmission went on it so
looking like we gotta replace that and i
don't know should we
you know scrape some extra together go
up to twenty thousand
twenty five uh and get the family
vehicle now and then keep going with the
1500
car and so we we you know save up and
replace that or do we just
replace it how much do you have in your
emergency fund
uh into our emergency phone we've got
about 25
20 about 25 000. how much do you say for
a car
about 10 right now so how did you get to
20
well that so that's what i'm wondering
because that 25
i'm wondering if we steal a little money
from the emergency fund
put it with the car fund to to replace
the vehicle now
what's your household income about 220
well i mean your emergency fund should
not be below
three months of your expenses
so what is three months of expenses for
you guys yeah three months of expenses
probably about
twelve fourteen thirteen got thirteen
thousand
fifteen fifteen is your minimum
emergency fund so if you move
if you move down an emergency fund and
move up a little bit in car and
immediately then
you're debt-free right correct
then immediately you start building that
emergency fund back up and building that
car fund back up because we need to get
out of that fifteen hundred dollar car
as well
you should do that at light and at
breakneck speed with your income you
have fabulous income what do y'all do
for a living
yeah uh i work for an engineering
services company doing sales
she's the nurse okay um
so the other little aspect with all this
is when we met she had a house
then i i bought a house once we got
married she moved in we turned hers into
a rental
we actually have a third one as well
that we have a rental that's a rental as
well
both of those two rentals we have about
fifty percent down
pay but we do have mortgages on those
now i'm including the mortgage on that
in the emergency fund number for that
fifteen thousand
for a three months is uh is includes the
mortgages on those as well
if you sold one of those could you pay
off the other one
yeah and and have the money to move on
up in cars right
yeah do it you need to move one of them
right now this market's hot
okay pick the one you don't like and
move it and let's let's clean this mess
up
because now you're sitting with two nice
cars paid for
a fully funded emergency fund and one
paid for rental property
i'd rather be there than where you are
okay
that's a good point okay
thanks for the call brother appreciate
you joining us
so can the um
when you've got a career that's cooking
like that it gives you lots of options
yeah yeah when you have an opportunity
to get promoted and move yourself up the
ladder
and keep financing uh the baby steps
and then when you have a situation like
the cars you can go do that get right
back into the emergency fund that is why
the great job is the big shovel it's a
game changer